on this sunday night
team canada makes a splash in tokyo
canadian women swim to silver winning
canada's first medals of these summer
olympics
the race to vaccinate health workers
target communities with lower
vaccination rates as covid cases surge
south of the border wildfire waiting
game
officials report fewer fires burning in
bc
while keeping a nervous eye on the
weather
national with robin gill reporting
tonight
jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us team canada has taken the podium
in tokyo the women are leading the way
picking up two silver medals in the pool
this country's first hardware of these
summer games
that silver finish also puts canada's
golden penny
into an elite olympic class crystal
comancing explains
in our top story with a silver medal
around her neck penny oleksiak's
collection
grows to five she is now tied as
canada's most
decorated summer olympian after the win
she said when she gets in the water
every time
it is to get a medal for the girls the
strength of the 21 year old from toronto
pulled the women's 4x100 relay team
towards the podium
and the first medal for canada at the
tokyo games
oleksiak rebecca smith maggie mcneil and
kayla sanchez have been swimming
together
for years and their bond is as solid as
their newly acquired hardware
sanchez called the victory sick jennifer
abell and melissa citrini
boleo also earned silver medals their
three meter syncro diving performance
started slow
but on their third dive they found their
groove and after number five
they knew they were on the podium
shortly after arriving in tokyo
citrini bulu explained why she and nobel
click i think the first thing is we're
not only
partners we're also friends and
we just have a really good communication
and
we enjoy what we do together these are
rebels
fourth games but the first for satrini
bolu
her parents watching back in canada
overjoyed by their daughter's success
the canadian women's softball team is
also looking to make everyone proud
they'll be playing for a bronze canada
has not won a medal in softball before
the women did come close in 2008
finishing
fourth that was the last year softball
was included in the summer games
crystal gomansing global news london
and the men's golf tournament has hit a
stroke of bad luck
the olympic event will get underway this
week without two of its top
athletes american golfer bryson
deschambeau and john rom
from spain both pulled out of the
competition after testing positive for
covid19
it's the second time in as many months
that rom the world's
top ranked golfer has tested positive in
june he was forced to pull out of the
memorial tournament with a large lead
despite the fact that he said he had
been vaccinated less than two weeks
earlier
so far there have been at least 137
coveted 19 cases linked
to the tokyo games well the world is
witnessing
a surge in kovid 19 cases largely driven
by the highly contagious
delta variant here in canada just over
half the population is now fully
vaccinated
but first dose vaccinations appear to
have hit a plateau
as catherine ward explains there's a new
push underway in toronto
to change that
with music in the air and open
invitations
the push to get covered 19 vaccines into
arms was in full swing in toronto on
sunday we really are targeting the 18 to
44 year old age group because we're
seeing that the vaccine rates are
slightly lower in that group
some people were there with loved ones
carrying big hopes to travel
abroad in south africa the vaccine the
whole vaccine process is very long it's
taking
quite long so i'd rather go now that i'm
fully vexed
than to go when i wasn't
thirteen-year-old gabby has her sights
set
on september and getting back in the
classroom i'm going to high school so
it's a new thing for me and i'm going to
meet a lot of new people and i think
like the vaccine is also going to help
me
with like not feeling nervous about
maybe spreading it
music to the air is for health care
workers doing what they can to encourage
people to roll up their sleeves
we need everyone to get their first and
second doses before school so we're
really keen to get our youth out
more than 80 percent of eligible
canadians have received one
shot 62 percent are fully vaccinated
as canada remains a global leader for
vaccine coverage
every inoculation is another piece of
collective protective armor
we've been very successful in getting
almost 20 percent of our doses
our first doses so we're really glad
about that because that means some
patients who have not had the
opportunity thus far
are able to walk in get their shot and
start their series
recent data suggests the country's
demand for vaccination is slowing
doctors say efforts like sunday's clinic
in toronto will help further move the
needle
in the right direction i think this is
going to pay huge dividends going
forward especially with the delta
variant because we are now
you know over 80 percent covered this is
going to really cut transmission chains
the risk is not completely gone but we
are in a much better position
than we were even a couple of months ago
catherine ward
global news toronto and the push is also
on to vaccinate more people
south of the border covid 19 cases are
rising in all
50 states and it comes just two weeks
before canada is set to reopen the
border to fully vaccinated american
tourists
as jennifer johnson explains frontline
doctors in the u.s are blaming vaccine
hesitancy across the u.s cobot 19
vaccination rates have hit their lowest
level
since late january 30 states have yet to
vaccinate at least half their residents
even as figures now show 99 percent of
all coveted hospitalizations and deaths
are among the unvaccinated the tragedy
is
every almost any everyone who's in a
hospital right now from covid
was there by choice doctors are pleading
with americans to get the shot to bring
this fourth surge of the pandemic under
control
but even some who have gotten sick and
hospitalized still doubt they'll get
vaccinated i had not received it in
retrospect
i honestly don't know if it would have
made a difference los angeles and san
diego counties are now reporting their
highest number of new cases since
february on monday
st louis will again mandate masks
indoors missouri's republican attorney
general plans to sue the city and
county even as cases in that state have
shot up 70 percent
in two weeks the uk variant was the most
contagious virus we had ever seen
it took over the entire state in three
months
the delta variant did that in three
weeks
san francisco's bar alliance is expected
to announce monday
bars will start requiring proof of
vaccination from customers
doctors are getting increasingly
concerned about what will happen in the
colder months ahead
as one model predicts a tripling of the
current death toll
by mid-october anyone who goes out and
gets vaccinated right now is going to
have a vaccine that protects them
through the fall in the winter
in florida where cases are also
skyrocketing
police officers in st petersburg are
going door to door
encouraging the unvaccinated to get
immunized as governor ron desantis joins
a growing list of republicans
now pushing the reluctant to get
protected
jennifer johnson global news washington
in brazil protests broke out in several
cities this weekend with residents angry
over the country's deepening kovid 19
crisis
in sao paulo last night protesters
clashed with police
after thousands marched earlier in the
day calling for president jair
bolsonaro's impeachment
polls suggest bolsonaro's popularity is
sinking after a slew of scandals
from his rejection of pandemic measures
to corruption allegations linked to
brazil's slow vaccine rollout
more than half a million brazilians have
died from covid19
and to another protest now happening
here at home thousands of migrant
workers took to parliament hill today
to call for changes to canada's
immigration laws they want access to the
same rights and freedoms enjoyed by
canadians
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken explains they hope to make
their cause
an election issue
most are not canadians and yet they've
come to the seat of canada's government
demanding rule changes which they hope
will set them on a path
to becoming canadian prime minister
trudeau has a test of his sincerity he
says he wants to build back better but
that's not possible when one in 23
people who are migrants without
permanent resident status
don't have equal rights without those
rights migrant workers were left
vulnerable during the pandemic these
guys
these guys are our farm worker like
myself
omar walcott points to the poster of
some of the 14 migrant workers
who died in canada last year most from
coven 19
caught in unsafe living conditions they
die
underneath tudor's watch you know so
i really think that tudor is responsible
for these guys
i think this this issue has come to the
forefront i think with covid
i think the this really put the
spotlight on these uh on on the
conditions that they're working in
so i think if if anything it'll be i
think more
on the on the minds of people when it
comes to election for sure the vast
majority of these migrants arrived in
canada legally
to help harvest food on canada's farms
or help care for the elderly the sick or
the very young
but as work permits or visas expired
they found themselves unable
or unwilling to return home because of
the pandemic
now 1.6 million are stuck in immigration
limbo
working in canada without labor law
protection or access to canada's health
care system
we work we contribute to the economy of
this country
i don't see why we should be treated
badly i don't see why we should be
treated separately
many like mayanway who is from cameroon
have been trying for years to become
a canadian citizen i love the country
it's always been my dream country
the opposition new democrats think that
the governing liberals are
vulnerable on this issue of how migrant
workers were treated during the pandemic
and in communities where there's lots of
immigrants think toronto vancouver
calgary you can bet liberal candidates
are going to be challenged to defend
that record
jeff david aiken in ottawa thanks david
still ahead wildfire watch crews are
battling more than 250 blazes in bc
well the weather brings some much needed
relief
[Music]
typhoon infa has now made landfall in
china the storm is pummeling the
country's east coast with powerful winds
and unrelenting rain
up to 35 centimeters could fall in some
areas
more than 300 000 people living near the
coast have been forced to flee
hundreds of flights and train services
have been canceled
and the public is being urged to remain
indoors
wow take a look at that terrifying scene
in india a massive landslide was caught
on camera
large chunks of rock came tumbling down
the mountain destroying a bridge in a
matter of seconds
at least nine people were killed several
others were injured
days of monsoon rains have triggered
deadly landslides and flooding
in many parts of that country and now to
the wildfire
fight in british columbia it is another
hot and dry day
with more than 250 fires burning in the
province
global's lauren pullen is keeping an eye
on the growing fire near the town of
oliver forest tonight so lauren
what's the latest on the situation there
some good news overnight jeff fire crews
tell me that no
new homes or properties have been
threatened and we
are now able to get close enough to take
a look at just some of
the aftermath fire just tore through
this entire hillside
near oliver it came alarmingly close to
homes that
are just up the road from here and this
spot is just one
of several areas throughout the region
that are charred by flames
and we are crews were still working
tirelessly of course as this fire
continues to grow
all the evacuation orders in place are
expected to stay with tensions
and concerns incredibly high
this fire would jump the road down here
and start burning his wagon
do you feel like they're getting it
under control at this point hard to say
and while there is good news with no new
evacuations it is still an uphill battle
to try and gain control of this blaze
we're still seeing challenges with the
weather conditions and smoke conditions
which can impede the ability of the
helicopters to get up in the air
we've been quite successful though with
those working around those conditions
and getting our crews out to those
communities that
have been threatened
a few hours north of here in sycamous
b.c where a wildfire has forced
basically the entire tourist town to be
evacuated
they are being told to expect to remain
out of their homes for at least
another week a major highway there
remains closed as well as crews continue
to fight those flames but the biggest
concern jeff across the entire region
continues to be this punishing weather
we are already
in the mid 30s the temperatures only
expected to climb
in the next week or so with no rain in
sight
jeff lauren pollen reporting near oliver
bc
thanks lauren still ahead getting to
know canada's first indigenous governor
general the story of mary simon
next
good evening ladies and gentlemen it's a
thrill to see me in poison
jackie mason thrilled many fans over his
legendary comedy career he passed away
saturday evening after being
hospitalized in new york for the past
couple of weeks
mason started his career as a rabbi with
a gift for injecting humor into his
sermons
before taking that wit from the
synagogue to the nightclub
over the years he became a regular on
the ed sullivan show
he won a tony award and an emmy award
for his one-man show
the world according to me don't get
nervous i'm not going to make fun of the
president of the united states i can't
stand anybody who makes fun of a person
just because he doesn't know what he's
doing
younger audiences may remember mason
best for his recurring role on the
simpsons
as rabbi hyman krastovski the father of
krusty the clown
he won an emmy for that one too by the
way jackie mason
was 93. and tonight we are on the eve of
a major milestone in canadian history on
monday
mary simon will be sworn in as canada's
30th governor general
becoming the country's first indigenous
woman to hold the prestigious position
david aiken reports the path to rideau
hall for mary simon
began in 1947 in the northern quebec
village of kanyak
an inuit village of a few hundred on the
shores of ungava bay
my mother was inuk and my father was
from the south
was manager of the local hudson bay
company post
i spent my adolescence in nunavik
living a very traditional lifestyle
as a child simon was forced to attend a
federal day school in nearby kujuwak
and she was forbidden to speak her own
language ignitute
and though the school was in quebec
instruction was in
english only by the 1970s she had joined
the cbc
northern service as a broadcaster and by
the end of the decade
she had begun her transition into public
service working for various
organizations
representing canada's inuit she knows
what it's like
living on the land where she's come from
and where she is today
but she has never ever forgotten where
she's come from
in the early 80s she attended
constitutional talks hosted by
prime minister pierre trudeau and
quickly made her mark
challenging the pm everybody's going to
shake their head and they're going to
say
well we spent way too much time on the
equality clause
and yet we're talking about a
fundamental right
i wish i wish you and your sisters would
take it out of your head that somehow
we're deliberately trying to frustrate
the concept of equality at least in the
law everybody is assured here
you hear that we are not simon
as people we have one interest
and that is our collective and
individual rights and all i'm saying
here is that
as someone that represents both sides
i'd like to see the equality clause once
and for all
settled in the 1990s the canadian
government would ask simon
to serve as canada's ambassador for
circumpolar affairs
and canada's ambassador to denmark most
recently
she has worked to improve inuit
education mary simon has been a diplomat
she has been a leader she also has run
foundations
in relation to children and youth she's
been a tireless advocate
for inuit
simon says she fully expects to continue
her lifelong work advancing the
interests of
inuit and other indigenous peoples now
as the canadian representative
of queen elizabeth ii there are
very important responsibilities
associated with my role that will help
the working relationship of canadians
and indigenous people
and beginning monday she will begin that
new chapter
in a life of work for the arctic and its
peoples
david aiken global news ottawa and that
is global national for this sunday night
i'm jeff semple tonight's your canada is
this pair of blue jays in sydney nova
scotia
thanks for watching have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you